et la dernière fois que votre cœur s'est
arrêté de battre Michel c'était pour qui
alors ce n'est pas pour qui je vais vous
dire c'est mon cœur s'est arrêté de
battre le jour où j'en ai tenu un qui
battait dans la main aïe aïe aïe
on va faire une interview de C4 je serai
plus sûr allez allez
[Musique]
d'habitude
c'est moi qui suis debout ça va c'est
quoi votre spécialité
proctologue
qu'est-ce qui vous fait mal au cœur
finalement aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez la télévision
sérieusement le manque d'audace et de
créativité le fait que dès qu'un truc
qui marche il est décliné 25000 fois
quand on regarde les émissions de
cuisine par exemple il y en a une qui
marche il y en a 25000 on sait plus que
c'est puis ça finit par tuer le sujet
Quelle est la Venette de la télé qui
vous donne des boutons
et puis s'il est il est chiant il a un
melon enfin c'est c'est très compliqué
et la dernière fois que votre cœur s'est
arrêté de battre Michel c'était pour qui
[Musique]
je pense que ma femme est en train de
regarder alors
ce n'est pas pour qui je vais vous dire
c'est mon cœur s'est arrêté de battre le
jour où j'en ai tenu un qui battait dans
la main aïe c'était sur une
transplantation cardiaque on avait
enlevé le coeur avant de transplanter le
nouveau et on m'avait mis le coeur dans
la main il battait encore parce qu'il
bat encore une fois qu'on le retire et
là ça a été un moment enfin drôle des
fois et quand vous entendez les hommes
politiques qu'est-ce qui vous rend
malade la langue de bois je supporte pas
je supporte pas de les entendre ne pas
répondre à une question sur quelle
période de votre vie aimeriez-vous être
amnésique vous vous appelez
Thierry
quelle cicatrice de la vie avez-vous
Michel
l'écriture de mon bouquin Hippocrate aux
enfers m'a laissé des des cicatrices de
ceux qui ont souffert pendant la joie
mais c'est par procuration moi
personnellement c'était pas et quelle
rumeur vous fait mal au cul
celle qui dit que je suis proctologue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était la peur de slt on se retrouve
sur terre après la pluie
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu